some breaking news this hour and five
police officers from four police forces
including the metropolitan police are
facing disciplinary action over messages
shared on social media about sarah
everard's killer wayne cousins well one
of the investigations by the independent
office for police conduct followed a
referral from the metropolitan police in
march it looked into allegations that a
probationary constable used whatsapp to
share with colleagues an inappropriate
graphic depicting violence against women
the investigation completed in august
indicated that the image was intended to
be in reference to the kidnap and murder
of sarah everard well that same officer
went on to staff a cordon as part of the
search for sarah according to the
investigation meanwhile another officer
will face a misconduct hearing after
allegedly sharing the graphic and
failing to challenge it well let's get
some reaction to this with nam chowdhury
who is the former detective
superintendent for the metropolitan
police thanks for your time uh this
afternoon uh first of all very serious
allegations what's your reaction
well to be honest with you when i read
the content of the misconduct findings i
actually felt sick to the stomach and
the reason i felt so sick was because it
just shows an utter disregard by
officers who feel that they can go and
behave in a certain way
at the most serious of crimes what does
that tell you about when they are going
out to deal with victims own
simple low-level crimes and how they
treat those victims it really did sicken
me i feel i feel so upset by it because
you join policing to protect the public
and to give victims a quality of service
i'm so gutted for the parents of sarah
everard
and as you say i mean this further
undermines doesn't it confidence in
policing which has already been hugely
rocked by the sarah everard case
well i think policing across the uk at
the moment is probably rock bottom in
terms of trust and confidence and this
has not helped it at all and i don't
think that you know the the
recommendations in terms of local
misconduct meetings because that's what
they are local misconduct meetings and
there is one gross misconduct that will
take place out of that that doesn't
really help the leadership at the top
and of course it's not just a met is it
i mean we know the met has come in for a
huge amount of criticism of late but
there are a number of different forces
caught up in this
well this is prevalent across the entire
uk within policing the officers feel
that it's acceptable to behave in a
certain way when it comes to victims the
bottom line is when you become a police
officer you police the uk 24 hours a day
and that means you have to act with
integrity and professionalism at all
times
what does it say about the culture of
policing um when this sort of thing can
go on and
and appear to be a regular occurrence
well i think that uh even with racism
and with sexism and clearly with
misogyny it's far more prevalent than
what perhaps people are thinking it is i
think that um it's not just a question
of female officers coming forward i
think it's the fact that male officers
are being exposed uh for their behaviors
which they think is just actually the
norm and perhaps that it's being treated
as the norm within policing because it's
classed as you know um banter which it
really isn't and part of the problem
here it would seem is that it's not just
uh instigating whatever it might be on
social media but it's failing to report
that bad behavior when you see it
well there's a fear to challenge that
behavior and i don't really understand
that i mean saying that you know a
probationer behaved in a certain way
when you join the police service you are
given the relevant training and you
should know as a common sense approach
that you are respectful to everybody so
you know the failure to challenge such
behavior because you think that you may
get targeted i've been targeted
all my service i actually honestly
didn't give a damn because what meant
more to me was standing up to be counted
and making sure that that kind of
behavior is eradicated
is the uk police um
are police forces around the uk
institutionally misogynistic do you
think
well i think that um the review for the
met police review and take undertaken by
um
sorry
um
i forgot her name casey i've on my
apologies but um i do think yes that
there's some form of misogyny that is
becoming far far more prevalent than
perhaps what even policing has probably
recognized and i think that needs to be
dealt with very very quickly
well let's talk about that then i mean
going forward what needs to be done
because it there needs to be a huge
cultural shift doesn't that
well i think some forces have already
recognized across the uk that there are
some serious changes that need to be
made i know that martin hewitt from the
national police chief council and
working with the with the npcc has
already indicated that there needs to be
some serious changes the metropolitan
police have uh you know um instigated
their own in like review with um as i
just mentioned but the fact is that i
think in some forces and i think my
metropolitan police i've been very clear
as much as i have huge respect for the
commissioner i think that it's time for
some new leadership and some new
direction
so you think crested dick needs to go
i think it needs new direction and i
think that probably answers the question
that you're asking yes yeah okay all
right we appreciate your time short
notice as well former detective
superintendent for the met
shabnam choudhury thank you